alright so our goal here at maxtec is to
help you guys get the most value
out of your tech purchases and we just
noticed that this morning
the 16-inch macbook pro just reached an
all-time low price of two thousand
dollars on amazon
that's 400 off if you enable the coupon
by using the link down below in the
video description
and i've basically never seen this good
of a deal on any macbook pro ever
including the 13 inch and the old 15
inch macbook pro models
so what i'm gonna do in this video is
clear up a lot of confusion
on whether you should buy one right now
or wait
for the apple silicon models because
there are people who should
wait so i'll discuss the rumors on when
we should expect
that 16 inch model with the apple
silicon and what benefits and
downsides there will be with that model
but first i want to show you guys just
how incredible of a deal this
is when we made our latest which macbook
should you buy in 2020 video
we compared the performance between each
macbook
including the more expensive quad-core
macbook air
and as you can see the base 16-inch is
definitely the most powerful
using cinebench r20 however if you take
a look at the score per dollar chart
the 16 inch model was only beaten out by
the 1300
macbook pro so score per dollar was
pretty decent
but in terms of graphics performance
using geekbench 5's metal test
the base 16 inch macbook pro is much
more powerful
so looking at score per dollar it's
clearly the best bang for the buck
and it's so powerful that it's the first
macbook we tested
that could actually do a great job at
playing triple a titles
like call of duty modern warfare using
boot camp
but just watch what happens when i redo
this chart using the current sale
prices of each macbook and then adjust
those numbers to show you just how good
of a deal
two thousand dollars is for the 16 inch
model the quad core macbook air is
currently 70
off but the base model is fully out of
stock so we're going with that quad core
price
of a thousand thirty dollars the base 13
inch macbook pro is currently 50
off right now and the high end 13 inch
is also 50 bucks off
so it shows that 400 off on the 16 inch
is a
really big deal with the new prices now
factored into the cinebench r20 score
per dollar chart
the base 16-inch macbook pro is now the
best bang for the buck
beating out the base 13-inch macbook pro
but now moving on to the graphics chart
this is just insane the 16 inch macbook
pro on sale for 2 000
now completely blows the other macbooks
out of the water
so this basically shows us just how good
of a deal this really is
compared to the other options right now
and then you also have to consider all
of the other benefits
like the redesign with the thinner
bezels and the much better speaker
quality
just listen to the sound comparison
[Music]
[Music]
so it's pretty clear that this is the
best bang for the buck we've ever seen
for any macbook pro and if you're in
need of a mac right now
there's no better time to buy however
there's also the fact that apple
is transitioning over to their armbase
max
so let's talk about that first off one
thing that's pretty much been confirmed
is that windows 10 support using
bootcamp is basically going away
and a lot of people love using it for
apps that are only available on windows
and for gaming since most aaa title
games are
only on windows so if you want windows
bootcamp functionality
especially with using an egpu it makes
the most sense to buy an intel-based
macbook right now
so you can continue to use it but if you
don't care about windows and you use
your macbook to make money
by using productivity apps like davinci
resolve 16
there's a pretty good chance that
apple's arm-based macs aren't going to
be fully optimized for a while
maybe even over a year so buying an
intel based mac means reliable
performance
until the apple silicon max proved
themselves to perform well
in third-party apps now on the other
hand
here are the benefits of waiting apple's
arm-based macs
are gonna be able to run iphone and ipad
apps
so if you enjoy mobile gaming and would
like the ability to play those games
on your mac using a gaming controller
then it probably makes sense for you to
wait for apple silicon max
now in terms of when those models will
come we expect
some sort of lower end macbook to be
released
later this year possibly at apple's
october event
but as far as the 16-inch macbook pro i
personally expect it to come in
the third quarter of next year so
sometime in the summer there's also a
small chance that apple will refresh the
16-inch macbook pro
this fall with 10th gen processors
but realistically you're still gonna
have to pay the full retail price of
2400. instead of the 2
000 deal right now and you've got to ask
yourself if it's worth risking the
possibility
of there not being an update until next
year
and missing out on this deal so it
really all depends on what your
priorities are
and what you want to use your macbook
for but if you're one of the people who
need
a macbook pro right now you literally
won't find a better bang for the bug
deal
so if you make up your mind you'll find
the link to that deal just below this
video
in the description below and if you want
more info on the switch to apple silicon
like apple dropping amd graphics support
and dropping dedicated graphics chips
you should check out that video right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you
in the next one
[Music]